[Music]
there's also big change for Steve
Harvey's talk show as it moves to LA
last night they held a big rap party in
Chicago but somebody was missing there
was no sign of Steve and that was after
a memo surfaced yesterday where he laid
down the law with the staff and this is
not going away anytime soon even after
Steve tried to clear the air with us by
phone people took this man and just went
crazy
today Steve poke fun at memo gate he
retweeted fellow comedian and talk show
host Chelsea Handler who apparently made
some four-letter modifications to his
now infamous staff letter to address
those working on her show Harvey
captioned it now this is funny in
hindsight I probably should have been
little bit different speaking
exclusively with et yesterday Steve
defended sending a memo last August
which in part reads do not come to my
dressing room unless invited if you open
my door expect to be removed my security
team will stop everyone who have the
intent to see or speak to me you can
still talk to me but you need an
appointment that was the whole message
behind
last night the Chicago staff who wrapped
production yesterday partied aboard a
boat we're told Steve was not there
because he said his goodbyes during the
day which were tearful but not
apologetic the show is moving to LA for
its sixth season with a mostly new crew
but a production source tells et Steve
doesn't have a bad reputation among
staff quote he's not rude to anyone and
he's so busy that quote having him asked
for people to respect his off-time is
not unreasonable my life is so busy
mm-hmm
I have so many job in addition to his
talk show Harvey hosts a national radio
show and several TV shows
Family Feud celebrity Family Feud and
little big shots
how do you do it all I mean it's just
management just manage your day yes you
do Stevie is a busy man now Steve's
talk-show from LA launches in September
[Music]
you